so let's say we have a pipe again
this is the
opening and we have fluid going through
it and the fluid is going with a
velocity of
v1
the pressure
entering the pipe is p1 and then the
area
of this opening of the pipe is a1
and then it's a pipe and it could even
go up
it goes up and the other end is actually
even smaller
and let's say that the the fluid the
liquid is exiting the pipe
with velocity
v2
the pressure that it it exerts as it
goes out let's say if there was like a
membrane on the outside how much
pressure would exert on it as it pushes
it out or whatever or on the adjacent
water is p2
and the area of the smaller opening it
doesn't have to be smaller is a2
and let's say that this opening is at a
height of i don't know let's pick a
let's say this opening is at a height on
average
of h1
and let's say
that this opening so the water exiting
this opening is on average at a height
of h2 and we won't worry too much about
the differential between the top of the
pipe and the bottom of the pipe we will
assume that these h's are much bigger
relative to the the size of the pipe
let's say this is h2
so with that set up and remember there's
fluid going through this thing
it's fluid going through this thing
so with that set up let's let's go back
to what would keep showing up which is
the law of conservation of energy which
is in any closed system the amount of
energy that you put into something is
equal to the amount of energy that you
get out
so energy in
energy in is equal to energy
out
well what's the energy that you put into
a system or that the system starts off
with at this end
well it's the work that you input
plus the potential plus the potential
energy
at that point of the system
plus the kinetic energy
of that at that point of the system
and then we know from the conservation
of energy that that has to equal
that has to equal
the output work plus the output
potential energy
plus the output kinetic energy
a lot of times in the past we just said
that the potential energy input plus the
kinetic energy input is equal to the
potential energy output plus the kinetic
energy output but we could also
so
the initial energy in a system can also
be done by work so we just added work to
this eq this equation that says that the
energy in is equal to the energy out so
with that information let's see if we
can do anything interesting with this
pipe that i've drawn
so what's the work that's being put into
this into the system well work is force
times distance
so let's just focus on this
it's the force
in
times the distance in
and let's say that so over a period of
time t what is what what has been done
so we learned in the last video that
over a period of time t
the fluid here might have moved
this far
and what is this distance
this distance is the input velocity
times
whatever amount of time we're dealing
with so t
so that's the distance
and then what's the force
well the force is just pressure times
area and we can figure that out by just
dividing
force we could divide this f by area and
then multiply by area so we get
input force divided by area
input times area input right i just
divided and multiplied by the same
number
and that's pressure that's area is equal
to the input
the input distance over that amount of
time and that's velocity times time
times velocity input times
time
so the work input is equal to
just
pressure
the input pressure
times the input area
times
the input velocity
times time
right
and what is
what is this
area this area
times velocity times time times this
distance
well that's the volume of fluid that
flowed in at
over that amount of time right
so that equals
the volume of fluid fluid over that
period of time so we could call that
volume in or volume i i keep switching
between the one and the i
but that's the input volume right and
and we know what we know that density
is
just
is just
mass
per volume
or that
or that volume times density is equal to
mass
or we know that volume is equal to mass
divided by density
so the work that i'm putting into the
system i know i'm doing a lot of crazy
things but it'll make sense so far
the work that i'm putting into the
system is equal to the input pressure
times the amount of volume of fluid that
moved over that period of time and that
volume of fluid is equal to the mass of
the fluid
that went in at that period of time
so we could call that the input mass
divided by
divided by the density
right hopefully
hopefully that that makes a little bit
of sense and as we know the input the
input volume is going to be equal to the
output volume so the input mass because
the density doesn't change is equal to
the output mass so we don't have to
write an input and output for the mass
the mass is going to be constant in any
given amount of time the mass that
enters the system will be equivalent to
the mass that
exits the system
so there we go we have an expression an
interesting expression for the work
being put into the system
what is the potential energy
of the system on the left-hand side well
the potential energy of the system
potential energy
input
is going to be equal to what
is going to be equal to that same mass
of fluid
right that i talked about
same mass fluid times gravity
times the this input height the initial
height times h1
and what's the initial kinetic energy of
the fluid
well that equals
the mass of the fluid this mass right
here that of that same cylindrical
volume that i keep pointing to
times the velocity of the fluid squared
this is just we remember this from
kinetic energy divided by two so what's
the total energy at this point in the
system over this period of time how much
energy has gone into the system
well it's going to be the work done
which is the input pressure
i'm running out of space
the actually let me erase all of this
and i'll probably have to run out of
time too
that's okay better than being confused
let me erase all of this i want to erase
everything
hope i'm not boring you
okay we're ready to go now
so back to what we were doing
so what's so the total energy going into
the system is the work
being done into the system and i rewrote
it in this format which is the input
pressure
the input pressure we'll call that p1
times the mass
divided by
the density of the of the liquid
whatever it is so this is
work in
plus
and what's the potential energy well i
wrote it right here that's just mgh
where m is the mass of this volume of
fluid
h is its average height you can almost
think of the center of mass how high is
the center of mass above
above
the surface of of the planet where since
we have a g here we assume we're on
earth
so this is
and this is h1 because the height
actually changes so this is
potential energy input
plus the kinetic energy
m
v
squared over 2
so that is
the kinetic energy
input
right
and we know we know that
this has to equal
the energy coming out of the system
right so let me clear up some more space
here
now that we wrote all that down neatly
we can get rid of it on this side and
we'll have space for our equations
i didn't have to delete this i probably
won't use this space up here
so this is going to be equal to the same
thing on the output side right
so this is going to be equal to the work
out so that'll be the output
pressure
times the mass divided by the density
plus the out
the output potential energy which will
just be m
g h 2
plus the outbound kinetic energy which
would be m
v 2
squared divided by 2. i just realized
i'm out of time so i will continue this
in the next video see you soon